and alec manual will face the orioles
for the second time in just six days
sixth start of the season his bigly
career right now alec maneau will get
the start he got a no decision in that
last start six days ago
cued up the third base line charging his
biggio has no play in field single for
galves oh yay freddie
going to pitch
let's go upstairs swinging in this
[Applause]
had to work a couple of strike assay or
of pair
blue jays get matt harvey again 780 irm
run average for harvey he's looking for
his first win since may the first
he has suffered the loss in eight of his
past nine starts pitched it against the
blue jays on the 20th
that one is hit on the ground great play
by franco spins throws got it
michael franco with a nifty pickup well
he's being the anti-dean kramer who
walked
mr contact here
there you go
just always get brooks robinson won 16
spring gold gloves well two steps in a
dive brooksy well there it is one two
dive catch it
and then he's got a strong accurate arm
so here's ronnie guerrero with nobody on
and cheers
he goes after the first pitch and rips
it right up the middle for a base hit
this blue jay team is the best first
pitch hitting team in baseball
this one is hit out to galvez
he'll make the play and matt harvey
despite allowing the two out single in
the wild pitch what's up his scoreless
first inning no score after one
no score bottom of the second it'll be
springer bizio and grichik for the blue
jays against matt
harvey hits one high and deep to center
field
[Applause]
welcome back george his first hit since
coming up
his third home run of the season and the
blue jays have jumped out on top here in
the second
a line drive right back to the mount
harvey turned away from it looks like it
hit him in the right hip
and it'll be a base hit for courier
and slashed in the left field for a base
hit
severino's gonna be held at third base
so cedric mullins with a base knock and
the orioles have something cooking
runners at the corners and nobody out
for galvez
it's this one sharp softly to shortstop
the shet one throws to first double play
but the orioles
get the run severino comes down to score
the scoreless drought is over and the
game is tied
[Applause]
guerrero goes after the first pitch high
and deep to center get up
he's two for two on two pitches
home run number 25 for guerrero and he
breaks the one one time
richard kisses from high and deep to
right this ball is up and off the wall
and then austin hayes stumbles and
glitching's headed for third here's the
throw from the right fielder it is not
in time
as randall grichard gets one off the top
of the fence in right field and ends up
with a triple
his first triple of the season and
courier alertis had an infield hit he
hit the line drive off harvey's hip
michigan third after the triple here's a
little roller up the third base line
parkour bobbles and he's going to be
safe which it comes in to score that
should be another infield hit for korea
richik with the two out triple comes in
the score and abuja has now made it
three to one
well there's a good slider as mancini
strikes out for a second time tonight
that's five strikeouts for bono this
might be his best slider of the night
ropes this one over bichette in the left
so another hit from mount castle against
alec manoa came up and in with a
fastball and mount castle turned it
around
he rockets that one through the right
side mount castle's gonna head to third
bridgex throw is not in time
and the orioles set up runners at the
corners with two outs off the sharp
single by dj stewart
another slider and he went around
so manoa indeed gets six innings in the
book he strands a couple of more base
runners and he will leave with a 3-1
lead bottom of the seventh inning
it'll be gurio maguire and then marcus
simeon back to the top of the order
notice guerrielle is two for two
up the middle he's got his third hit of
the night off the glove of malaika
muriel has three singles
[Music]
and there's another base hit the left
field for reese maguire
he's got that stroke down pat
beautiful swing as he
gets another base hit
so that'll turn the line up over with
two aboard and nobody out going over
marcus simeon the laid off man he is
over three so far
look down the left line that's gonna
score one for sure maguire is coming
around third he's going to score the
throw is laid into the infinite as
marcus simeon delivers once again
he's been terrific in the seventh inning
and later and comes up with a big
two-run double here in the center
here's mount castle rounds this one up
the middle it's past pachette in the
center mullins coming around
springer can't get a lid on it rbi
single for mount castle the orioles make
it 5-2 tying run of the plate santander
pinch hitting
santander hits that one off the mound
and in the left center field they'll
give the wave around to galvez hill's
score throw goes in the third rbi base
knock santander the orioles have made it
a two run game
lines this one out to center field this
ball is headed to the wall it'll bring
in mount castle they're waving around
santander thrown to the plate he is safe
the orioles have tied the game up at
five on the two run double by austin
hayes mancini represents the go ahead
run at third
and he lays off his slider for ball four
so the bases for the orioles are loaded
up
and he walked him
forces in the go ahead run six five o's
25 pitches 15 for balls 10 for strikes
and the third walk that he has handed
out in the center
2-2
got him
orioles hang on six to five in 10
innings and the orioles road losing
streak is over and we're never talking
about it again
the 20-game streak snapped the orioles
or winners 6-5
in buffalo in 10 innings